you were inducted into the Hockey Hall
of Fame obviously in a year was 1999
did you ever visit because I'm trying to
imagine Wayne Gretzky visiting the
Hockey Hall of Fame it would be such a
surreal experience if anyone saw you you
know any man I love going there and so
kind of put a hat on in pair of glasses
and I have a two kids were born after I
retired and really didn't know who I was
and didn't know my career and he was
about nine years old and I said look
we're gonna go to the Hockey Hall of
Fame it's pretty cool but just I'm gonna
keep my head down and don't be saying
anything so we went for about two hours
and they have this interactive part of
the Hockey Hall of Fame down below and
you can take shots so we got in line
with all these kids my son got out there
and he was four for five he said dad you
should try this and I said okay I'll try
it so I'm I'm oh-for-three
no really yeah and the kid was directing
the line came over and said sir just
move your hand down the stick to my hat
up and I said okay I'm out here he must
have had a heart attack yeah I was very
funny
you